hello sir how'd you find us out muller's
fourth symphony he'd never sit in just
any section i might i'm flexible oh
really you'd sit
center left in timpani alley i'll
purchase those tickets right away
no don't fine jake is helping me with a
burglary here at the university and i
asked him
not to tell you is this about saint
augustine yes what's going on he's
embarrassed of me last christmas the
classics department through a holiday
party i had one drink too many
and utterly humiliated myself and that
was the point saying augustine was
making in consolation of philosophy
yeah sounds super humiliating saying
something smart smart i confused saint
augustine with boethius
i might as well have stepped on a rake
and bonked myself in the forehead the
problem wasn't what you said
it was that dean alistair pointed out
your mistake and you lost your damn mind
i misremembered it because i'm reading
both simultaneously one book is too few
for me
it was quite the kerfuffle the problem
is is that i get flustered and defensive
because i know how they all
see me it's kevin's working-class
bimbo i can't imagine that's what they
think it is really obviously i know that
they're wrong but
they put you in your own head and you're
not yourself around them i'm sorry i was
just
trying to protect you yes of course
thank you for saving me from myself
now if you'll excuse me i'll just go sit
by the pool and read some fiction
like the bimbo that i am
[Music]
there's a pool here ah dean alistair
police man raymond
good to see you read any interesting
magazines lately
this again i was waiting for kevin i had
finished my book and i happened to
glance at a
issue of the economist that someone left
lying about all i remember is you
becoming unhinged
the only reason i picked it up was the
swatifly i mean i'm not crazy
why are there always flowers here so is
policeman raymond joining the case
actually he's leading it captain holt is
the finest investigator i've ever worked
with sir tell him our plan of action
clues okay you're freezing up i'm just
gonna take the wheel for now there were
no signs of forced entry the only people
with access to the archives were the
professors in the department and they
all have alibis which means
uh what you want me to say okay that's
my fault for throwing it to you again
which means we need to examine the crime
scene it is there that we will find what
captain holt has so eloquently described
as
sir you just said it and a big round of
applause for janitor randy for
recovering our precious coin
don't applaud for that man what's going
on what's going on is
captain holt just solved this case
what's that left to solve we found the
coin in professor
port's desk he's the thief oh you'd like
everyone to believe that wouldn't you
dean alistair or should i say
general parmigiana raymond are you
causing a kerfuffle yes
sometimes the moment calls for a
kerfuffle no no moment calls for a
kerfuffle you know my feelings on this
dean alistair framed
professor port to get rid of a rival
just as alexander
got rid of parminion preposterous do you
even have a shred of evidence to back up
that claim oh we've got more than a
shred look at these photos
here a footprint from the scene of the
crime left by the thief
and here another print made yesterday by
you
you've been caught alistair is it
happening caught by me it is happening
me and my
rock-hard brain it happened oh raymond
look around these shoes i'm wearing with
their unique
footprint we all have them they were the
departmental gift this christmas they're
actually very funny
they have achilles printed on the heel i
don't know if i would call that very
funny i'm surprised you didn't know
about them
kevin must have gotten a pair oh i
remember what happened you had to leave
the christmas party before they were
handed out
why was that again oh yes but kerfuffle
but what about the autobiography of
persimmons you were taunting us with i
suppose i can see how
holding any book would seem like a taunt
to you i own a book i don't think
raymond is remembering the story
correctly
alexander didn't see parminion as a
rival he killed him over a dispute about
his son
oh no it's boethius all over again at
least you've got one thing right you do
have a
rock-hard brain because that's bad
everyone knows that a brain should be
soft and wet i wanted to say that but
jake told me not to
yeah because it's gross yeah i stole
those coins i can't believe you bought
that old story they underestimated you
randy just as they underestimated
raymond holt uh you guys haven't been
that great to me either well you got to
teach people how you want to be treated
randy dr phil r.i.p
the point is captain holt solved the
case when no one else could he's
actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel alistair you're an
embarrassment really well at least i've
never confused scent augustine with bow
etheus oh who gives a rat's ass about
boethius wesley what are you doing kevin
i'm creating a kerfuffle oh damn
sure my husband is a hot piece of ass
but he is so much more than just that
raymond holt is as smart as anyone in
this department but he chooses to use
his intelligence
to make our city a better place
one day i hope to live up to the
standard you set you make me want to
have
a wetter brain i'm kevin
[Music]
y'all are hella specific
you